[Music]
joining us now with reaction to
tonight's breaking news the author of
the New York Times bestseller Trump's
America the truth about our nation's
great comeback former Speaker of the
House Fox News contributor Newt Gingrich
great to see you I'm ready to be with
you now the bar seems to be moving I
have a source telling me well the three
public and senators Murkowski Collins
snowflakes are that's my nickname now
maybe it's about temperament maybe he
didn't respond the right way when he
went before the Senate and was showed
righteous anger and indignation after
being accused of being a gang rapist I
would be very surprised if Susan Collins
would do that I think she's a serious
person I think she really set a standard
and said let's get an investigation
apparently we don't know but apparently
the FBI came back and said there is
nothing there it's what they reiterated
the Senate Judiciary investigation yeah
nobody changed this story my guess is
that you've got senator Collins and
Senator Murkowski are solid people
they've talked this through I think they
will vote for the judge I don't know
what flake will do although he had
indicated pretty clearly if the FBI
comes back with nothing he's going to
vote yes and I think that the odds are
pretty high that Manchin senator from
West Virginia
is going to vote yes when you when
you're in a state where Trump got forty
six percent margin you know have a
certain level of fear up for reelection
presumption so I think tonight I mean
maybe things will change but my sense is
tonight that you're gonna have either
Saturday or Monday a vote of the yes
vote and he's going to be confirmed all
right so I hope you're right 34 days
from now I knew you back in 94 you the
day before the election I saw you and
the day of the election I saw you this
is the night you became Speaker of the
House this is you know a foundation of
renewing American civilization
culminating in a contract with a
culminating and Republicans coming to
power for the first time in 40 years
and confident oh we're gonna win that's
a pretty bold prediction when
considering Republicans had won in 40
years but you were right you have a
degree of optimism about the election in
34 days
maybe it's because I'm Irish maybe
because I'm always expected the worst
the next second of any day but I don't
have that confidence that you do well
you know I think I'm a lot like Reagan
and that I really believe in the
American people and I really believe the
average American saw all of this
character assassination smearing
dishonesty manipulation and I think they
look at a Republican team led by Trump
that is really delivering and getting
things done and so then they look over
here at these Democrats who have really
been trying to block everything and they
got results over here real results jobs
breakthroughs on trade things that are
happening that are tremendous and
they'll cover here at these people who
seem to fight everything and I said this
is what happened to me in ninety in 2016
because I remember doing the show with
megyn kelly two weeks out and I finally
said you know I just don't believe in
fact that's it it's in the tape I said I
don't think the American people are
gonna elect somebody as corrupt as
Hillary Clinton period I didn't believe
it about the American people now it's
close race I do not believe tonight that
the American people are gonna reward
left-wing socialist people who want to
obstruct everything by giving them power
so I'm moderately optimistic I wouldn't
you know bet the family farm but I might
bet a horse or two okay I'm glad to hear
but look it comes down to individual
districts right this is and there are a
lot of new people a lot of retirements
this year that raises an unknown
question
I do think mansions in trouble I think
Nelson's in trouble I think Donnelly's
in trouble at the Claire McCaskill's in
trouble thank you
down 12 now in the Fox box isn't
Rochester in Montana there's a lot that
can happen some of these races are very
close but some incumbent Democrats right
33 I think the Senate yeah
we are very like then by the way I think
in Minnesota you're gonna have a you
have a very real possible an upset
because I think that the Republican
nominee is a very attractive woman and I
think the Democratic nominee who was the
lieutenant governor has to carry this
whole burden of Keith Ellison and given
everything Democrats have said about you
know unsubstantiated allegations I mean
how does she campaign in a ticket with a
guy who said two different women say
then he abused them why did they ask for
the FBI investigation into him or if
we're going to go back to Cavanaugh's
teenage years we could at least go back
to the time that Bill Clinton was the
Arkansas Attorney General can't we
well--that's once you open this up and I
saw I just think you know the
president's going to be in Minnesota
tomorrow he's gonna have a chance I
think to important House seats in
Minnesota California in New York right
states that you wouldn't think where the
house has been play and in a number of
these places he's gonna be able to go in
campaign for the House member and the
senatorial candidate and you could see a
sweep building that would be
breathtaking and I think on the Senate
side we were gonna clearly gain seat
you're the historian it's only happened
three times in a hundred years party
wins the White House and doesn't lose
seats in the in the first midterm - I
don't I don't to sound silly about this
but all I can say is a historian is
you've never had Donald J Trump I mean
you're a different world right now
you've got you have somebody who is a
great natural campaigner dope supporters
understand that what they voted for in
2016 that they've tried to tear down
almost from day one and destroy him do
you think they know that that's all in
jeopardy I think that the liberals
assault on Kavanagh has aroused
conservatives and moderates decent
people people who believe in the rule of
law people who believe in fairness I was
at Phoenix yesterday with about 850
at a radio station that's not quite the
size of a trump rally no no I get my and
and neither he nor I get six million
people and evening okay get a Hannity
Brooker but the point is the people I
saw were on fire they are sudden there
was a big Sally they want to make sure
that we know and she'll be a great ally
Heller in Nevada's are all races that
could be there could be listen it's
close it is every votes gonna matter so
I'm gonna be an optimist and say if we
get out to vote if we tell our story if
we don't let up we're gonna do fine Mr
Speaker good to see without the bike
great to be in the swamp where you live
oh no you live in Italy now I forgot
congratulations